oh back home now to the breaking news
overnight the social media app Tik talk
going dark in case it does I don't want
the last video that I post to be
screaming and yelling at the
camera you know when you're driving
people to like really sad depressing
stuff and that can lead to Al Che on a
caller one street RP is saying they love
Tik Tok and is very incoherent big
reason you know that you don't you don't
want that in your Society I opened Tik
Tok and it's gone and there's no Tik
Tock I've done it like five six times
it's just an empty Barren land give it
back to me
please and as of today Tick Tock is
back so I guess we're not going to get
banned on Tik Tok yeah that was quick we
it was like I took a nap and it was back
yeah seriously I was like move
everything off of Tik Tok just kidding
move it back we have a Tik Tok Channel
although we haven't put a lot of energy
into it um it's got some pretty wealthy
videos about anime and stuff so now is
it or is it well Trump was like I think
he was cool with it being shut down
until his dancing videos went viral on
Tik Tok well he had dancing videos yeah
his little you know little show that we
need to show that
I don't know series with the Village
People
[Music]
it's I think it was he has his iconic
little dance emote but anyway it brings
up um you know a couple of things one
there was there's this whole Free Speech
issue at hand and then there's also
According to some people National
Security
implications and so I was digging around
on the internet I found this this clip
of Step coar talking to somebody who's a
national security adviser I just thought
it was interesting so I want to show it
to you guys and then talk about it and
then we'll take it from there here's the
question is Tik Tock a security threat
or an economic Boon for the Creator
economy or neither or both I would say
both look I'm the of three School AG
daughters I've got two teenagers they're
Doom scrolling all day long and yes
there's candy salads and slime videos
and occasional trauma dump but there's
also another side of Tik Tock okay which
is that China is engaged in an ongoing
and unrelenting effort to hack the
United States to gather our personal
information to gather our financial
information to hack into our electrical
grid our water systems our financial
systems and now they've got a
surveillance tool in everybody's pocket
on everybody's phone because this
Chinese software can amass all that data
Harvest it together and they can build
an incredibly large dossier of American
personal information and they can use
that to steal passwords to hack into the
electrical system the water system the
financial
systemate how does China do that from
like hacking in and knowing what that
your daughters are watching trauma dumps
like I don't how did that then that hack
the electrical system because the
software doesn't just have funny videos
it also collects everywhere you go
everybody you talk to everybody you work
with it can also turn on a microphone it
can amass an a mass massive amount of
information that when you put it all
together Stephen constitutes a major
cyber risk to the United States and our
critical infrastructure okay there there
plenty of social media companies should
be others that we should be banning I
think the key distinction here is that
if a Chinese owned company has software
on the phone of 170 million Americans
it's a serious national security threat
and there's another issue Stephen which
is that because that recommendation
algorithm is so strong it's what makes
Tik Tok so addictive and so interesting
to watch that's an that's an opportunity
for China to influence not just
influence our young people you know
often times the first thing that my
daughters know about an issue whether
it's a wildfire or school shooting or
politics or the Middle East or Ukraine
they've learned from Tik Tok often times
it's the only thing they know so if
there were a geopolitical crisis and
China wanted to use its algorithm to
advance certain narratives certain
information certain propaganda if we
were in heaven forbid a war with China
this would be the mother of all
propaganda platforms that China could
use so you notice how he just completely
avoided the question about other social
media companies like it's okay as long
as they're American owned you can invade
anybody's privacy no big deal yeah and
and it's funny that with this I was uh
it's been going on for a while right
this talk about banning Tik Tok and
stuff and uh just recently I think was
today yesterday I saw a few clips of
when it was being talked in Congress
they were like interviewing I think was
the creator of Tik Tok or like this this
one guy and there were like some
questions they were making to make sure
they really wanted to catch it as a
security threat but at the same time it
sounded like they didn't want to make it
obvious that America does the same like
they would ask questions like so if I am
on Tik Tok and I use my
airpods does the airpod can the airpods
read my brain and collect information
straight from my
brain or or uh okay so apparently the
the guy who created this from Singapore
not China but they kept trying to
connect them to China and stuff like
that and there's like this whole
confusion they really wanted like to
just yeah hate on it for some reason
interesting yeah the um the other thing
I found very interesting was um the
propaganda issue it's like well you know
if there's this other country and they
have the ability to influence our
citizens it's like well you have the
ability to do the same thing or those
companies that that let's say they're
privately owned how do how am I supposed
to trust their agenda it's like I'm from
the government and I'm here to help yeah
I really wonder if if Tik Tok came from
America like it was like YouTube would
they even be saying the same sort of
thing no absolutely not absolutely not
with other countries would they be
turning around going man these Americans
are totally too much into our kids
I mean it probably has happened in other
countries I think in 2006 YouTube was
banned from certain Middle Eastern
countries but America is too popular I
guess to ban anything from them it's
okay if the movies are programming the
kids just just not Tik Tok it reminds me
of um oh what is that that documentary
on Netflix um social social the social
dilemma man that that talks about this
kind of stuff too you know like like it
it it's totally gathering information
whether whether it's Facebook or
Instagram that's that's us owned or
whether it's you know something they can
all turn your cameras on you have to
agree to this kind of stuff they can all
turn your microphones on I mean Ser
nobody read that have you ever have you
ever noticed that you say something
random and it pops up in your Amazon
like I suggest like I I think I once had
a conversation about hammock chairs MH
and I'm like I like look on Amazon I'm
like why are hammock chairs suggested on
Amazon or I literally a kid you not I
walked into a Walmart I picked up a
packet of cat treats I'd never bought
them before put them back I go out I
look at my Walmart app and it's
suggested to me and I'm like that's
creepy wow you know I think that the way
you scroll as well if you're slowing
down and looking at something that's
feeding them information that you're
interested in that thing it so even if
just like have a picture that flies by
and you just stop and Breeze look at it
for a few seconds and then keep going
that's telling them oh she likes that
I'm going to feed her more so I want to
talk about a couple of biblical
principles and then talk about Tik Tok
more in depth and I think there's some
other reasons to be concerned not just
you know the government is spying you
whether it be the US government or the
Chinese government or people are just
brain
dumping first thing I want to bring out
is this biblical principle from 1
Corinthians 10:31 you want to read that
for us yeah sure therefore whether you
eat or drink whatever you do do all to
the glory of God one of the reasons
I gave up largely on social media was
because of this principle it's like look
if I'm going to be on social media or
engaged in social media I need to be
devoted to this concept and if I can't
do that then really how is it benefiting
me how is it benefiting my neighbor mhm
and so um I'm not saying you can't do
that that's not for me to decide I'm not
anybody's judge I'm just saying this is
a good principle to live by if you're
engaged to something you know then this
should be your aim to do whatever you're
doing to the glory of God you know I
recently had had this really wild
experience with God where you know God
has been convicting me that um I need to
start my day with him and not go to the
gym first cuz I like going to the gym in
the morning before work and before I
would like oh go to the gym and after
when I come back I'll wor study God's
word it doesn't matter and God convicted
me I have to switch it around so he's
been trying to help me to wake up early
in the morning earlier study and then go
to the gym well this morning I was um
kind of half sleeping still praying you
know half sleeping dozing off and it was
like 10 minutes to 5: and I'm like oh no
I supposed to get up at 5 and like go
get ready for the gym and so I quickly
read a devotional got in my car and
started driving to the gym and as soon
as I got on the road God was like what
are you doing aren't you supposed to
spend time with me I have no other gods
before me and I kid you not it was a
battle I drove to the gym it's about 10
minutes 12 minutes and I went back and
forth with God the whole time trying to
make excuses being like well maybe this
is not the Holy Spirit speaking to me
and God's like you think you yourself
have these kind of convictions of course
it's me speaking to you all these things
and he kept saying have no other gods
before me turn around and I'm like uh no
but but and I turn around here no but
and I finally got to the gym and God was
like I have no other gods before me I
was like okay fine and I turn around and
I had this heavy burden on me the whole
time and as soon as I turn around it is
just like absolute peace like I knew I
was doing the right thing um and I had
devotions at home and it was amazing but
then it really struck me like these kind
of things can become false gods in our
lives and it's the same with social
media I don't want any false gods in my
life yeah that bu not I you know what I
mean they not always bad things I um it
was a couple years ago I think I I
preached at church and I had made this
call to for people to why don't you put
away you know some social media app that
you're using for a space of time and for
me at the time it was Twitter and I
thought you know what if I'm calling
people to do this I need to be willing
to do the same thing and so I did and I
haven't used Twitter since I I think
it's so mentally freeing when your mind
is not clogged with this kind of stuff
but when because we come up with with
this all the time well I don't have much
time for god well do is that really the
case or how much time we spending
scrolling the internet or on YouTube
that we could be studying God's word if
you think about the the addiction is
really the new information right you're
you're you're you're hoping that you're
going to see something new that's going
to be beneficial to you but isn't that
what you're finding out when you're
reading the word of God exactly some new
piece of information like get addicted
to that and and and what what can I
learn more about you God so one of the
things that is um interesting is I was
watching this piece by The Wall Street
Journal and they were they had made a
whole bunch of Tik Tock Bots um for
themselves they wanted to see how does
this thing work how is it affecting
people what's it doing they were trying
to figure out the algorithm the Wall
Street The Wall Street Journal so they
made they made these fake yeah 200 like
fake accounts that were run by Bots and
then they just gave them very few
parameters very little information and
then LED them to click on certain things
one thing that's really fascinating is
one of the Bots that it created it was
supposedly
depressed and what that led to was that
uh the algorithm feeding that bot
93% of the videos it fed it were
depression related wow so was the bot
like preset to be depressed yeah I mean
and and it's not I mean it's a bot it's
not really depressed but like that was
his interest and so it would Linger on
depressing videos or sad content and
then it just started feeding
it more and more and more so that's a
high rate and you know when you think
about reasons for something being banned
I'm not saying ban Tik Tok or don't ban
Tik Tok but but if I'm considering a
reason why something is Maybe not the
best for the the
public I would say this you know when
you're driving people to like really sad
depressing stuff and that can lead
to especially among teens big reason you
know that you don't you don't want that
in your Society right not saying don't
have the ability to express yourself I'm
having a bad day I'm depressed but that
should never lead to people talking
about should never get that I'm justy
trying to think of a reason why if you
were the creator of the the Tik Tok
program and and you were to say okay
like I'm going to just force it to not
like depression if somebody's showing
all these depressive signs how do you
avoid this and start showing them happy
things or something like this right you
if you have the technology to help
somebody why wouldn't you why would you
just let it literally feed something
somebody that could potentially kill
them and that shows the bias in the
interest of the company because it's
more about keeping somebody engaged
which makes them money mhm not getting
them help yeah rather than you take a
few of these things that you know of our
bad ways that that that are going to pan
out like that and change it yeah so I
found this really helpful summary on um
the University of British Columbia and
it was called addictive by Design how
Tik Tok keeps you hooked so if you want
to know this is basically what they're
doing going to pull the curtain back so
to speak and the first thing is um they
look at all these things in the
algorithm it's just like what accounts
you follow creators you've hidden com
comments you've posted videos you've
liked or shared videos you've added to
your favorites videos you've marked as
not interested videos you reported as
inappropriate longer videos you watch
all the way to the end so looking at
your completion rate and content you
create on your own so they're they're
looking at all these variables
especially like Scotty just said like
that amount like how much time you spend
on a video if it's a second longer than
another video that's going into the
algorithm and saying hey there's
interest there we need to find out what
they like about that video and sometimes
it can take 40 minutes in that Wall
Street Journal uh video when they did
their investigative reporting it took 40
minutes in some cases for them to figure
a a bot out or a person out like this is
what it's like beat it more just not
very much
time what else did they find well less
choices make less chances to leave do
you want to read that highlighted
portion Scotty Tick Tock ux designers
embody the principle known as Hicks law
this principle stat that the more
choices users have it's harder for them
to make one when we reduce the number of
decisions that our brain needs to make
we go into autopilot so this is why you
don't have Endless Options when you go
to the grocery store when you go out to
eat or what have you it's like you know
why does the movie theater only show
like a handful of options they're not
going to give you everything under the
sun they want you to make a decision and
they need you to do it quickly so they
can be efficient but you know as like
you go to grocery store and it's like
there's two kinds of detergent you know
like there's a Walmart brand and there's
the name brand maybe there's another one
but then there's not too many and I've
noticed over time how a lot of them get
removed and you just you can't get them
anymore right so that's playing into
this it's also addictive by Design did
Ne you mind reading the highlighted
portion there is a surprising or maybe
not so surprising inspiration behind
this addictive design casinos Tik Tok is
not the first app to pull their
inspiration from casinos but they have
certainly perfected it modern casinos
rely on the psychological tactic coined
by BF Skinner called operative
conditioning this Theory suggests that
people can be trained to exhibit certain
behaviors through programmed rewards
I've heard about this before yeah but
that was also in um the social dilemma
they talked about that it's really not
necessary for you to have to pull P down
your feed in order for it to you know
show you new stuff that's I mean it can
refresh all the time if it wants to it's
literally that movement is like a slop
machine yeah BF Skinner this operative
operative conditioning stuff plays in in
a lot of society and um you know we're
going to get to one of the things about
the scrolling here in a minute but you
know it's like there's so much
psychology that goes into all this kind
of stuff and you think about like video
games right you should me this you know
why does the progress bar in your health
on a video game never get
full right yeah something always to do I
mean it's like it's you know get D yeah
it's always not full length yeah might
get full for like momentary right right
but it's it's almost like low all the
time or there's and it could be just
like health or it could be something
else something you're collecting or
whatever but it's like you then feel
that drive to like oh I got to fill that
thing up right it's weird I I almost do
the same thing with the Prius that I
drive and it's like the battery I want
to get it all the way full so like do
the regenerative break ging but another
Bible principle that we can draw out of
this um from 1 Corinthians 6:12 all
things are lawful for me but not all
things are helpful all things are lawful
for me but I will not be brought under
the power of any if we are participating
in things that are really holding us
there like keeping us addicted keeping
us in them and it has more power over us
than we have over it that's not God's
design no right God wants us to be free
he came the Bible says to set the
captives free so we need to be free in
Christ not be brought under another
power and I like too that it says um
some things are lawful but might not be
helpful like in my experience the gym is
great it's very helpful but it and it's
lawful but it cannot be put before my
time with God you know spend your time
with God you go to the gym and it's the
same with YouTube YouTube is not in and
of itself bad there's plenty of stuff
you can watch you can watch Christian
stuff you can watch nature stuff you can
learn stuff but it's like once it
becomes addictive and unfortunately
that's the problem it's designed to be
addictive that's when it's like you know
maybe you should not like not as watch
as much anymore or maybe you should
completely step away from it if it's
really a problem yeah all right well how
else does Tik Tock work there's also the
near win principle would you mind
reading that bipe when a reward is 100
steps away your initial step progresses
you only 1% towards your payoff however
once you are almost in reach the payoff
for each effortful Act is much higher
meaning we become more physiologically
aroused and ready to act but should the
word be snatched away the Readiness to
act doesn't disappear yeah so
fascinating right and what else do we
have Tik tok's design Scotty so how does
Tik Tok borrow from these design
principles the most obvious feature
would be in the infinite
scroll never ends never ends there's no
bottom of it I think Pinterest was the
first one that really did that I think
or it might have been Facebook yeah I
don't I don't know but it's it's pretty
powerful you know and then that
translates over to other kinds of
websites you know eCommerce websites or
whatever instead of
pting things so just like make it as a
go till it ends and some of these things
have no bottom I have certainly found
myself scrolling like this and then kind
of caught myself minutes later and be
like how long have I been doing this you
know and it's just like yeah you just
kind of get roped in like a tractor beam
yeah the average viewing sensation I
think it is on YouTube YouTube was like
40 minutes but people don't watch really
long videos so it's like one short video
to the next M it's really easy to watch
40 shorts yeah compared to one long 40
minute sermon to say oh I know right how
do you get out of this how do you take
back control there's some principles
this article brought out which I thought
were pretty good and can help us um take
back that control that we need to one of
them is that we can set a timer on our
phone for the time of day you want to
spend on Tik Tok or the time you want to
spend on Tik Tok so in other words just
set a timer and say you know what giving
myself 10 minutes that's it the timer
goes off I walk away and that requires a
lot of self-control on your part you
have to sck comes down to discipline
yeah it is it's discipline isn't it
what's the next one uh denique you can
also set different timers for all your
social media apps yeah it doesn't have
to just be Tik Tok right it it can be
anything yeah so different times
different timers you might find some
more addicting less addicting whatever
but it needs to be reasonable and we go
back to that first thing we brought out
we should do this to the glory of God
Amen all right next uh principle on
there Felipe practice intentionality
with the content you engage with don't
spend time watching commenting or
sharing content that gets you
heated o only watch the stuff you like
cat videos won't get you heated compared
to politics right well that means I'm
good I like this though practice
intentionality the same thing is told by
um medical experts when it comes to
Children you should not sit your
children down in front of anything
without intentionality and then we say
when you're engaging with something you
should do it together so that you're
helping them understand this world that
they're being introduced to
and it's not just aimless so you know if
they see something you can help them
make sense of it help guide them and
you're also helping them by monitoring
the time and saying okay now we've done
this we're going to go on a lot of this
stuff is used for school now right so
you may be the parent it's like okay
part of our curriculum is to watch this
cool YouTube video but it doesn't mean
for the next three hours we're going to
watch YouTube videos right you do it
together and you make sense out of what
you're seeing this one I don't know if
you've heard this one before denique um
the next tip a more extreme tip is to
change the display in your phone to gray
scale I have not heard about that but
that's a and white yeah do you know why
I just I just think it's cool I have it
on my phone but psychologically color is
more appealing and so you're more likely
to spend time or be drawn to those very
colorful things and if it's in Gray
scale your brain is like not as
interested and so it's like eh I can
give this up that is interesting yeah we
can see this with the children content
right I mean if we look like shows like
Coco melon they make sure to saturate
that all the way to make sure children
keep staring at colorful things and
think about our past like we had
newspapers right black and white and
over time what evolved there was like
magazines or colored newspapers or what
have you you know got to Bright and
catchy is that why Leave it to Beaver
was so boring
it's black and white maybe all right you
want to read the last tip Scotty if
you're finding that you just can't stop
using Tik Tok or any social media app
and it's having a serious impact on your
mental health maybe it is time for a
digital detox I want to add to that if
it's impacting your relationship with
God yeah yeah that's the most important
thing and I think it's impacting pretty
much everyone's relationship yeah and
you brought up a good point about the
morning or the evening you know and
spending time with God you know if
that's a last thought that is on your
mind when you go to sleep your brain
goes to sleep digesting all these images
that it just saw right right when you
wake up what's the first thing most
people do they pick up their phone and
they check it yeah so you know it's the
first thing and and and I I mean I'm
guilty of this like your phone starts
dinging you start responding to people
right off in the morning and it's like
you you're off to the race is already
like dealing with work stuff and you
don't get that that quiet time so yeah I
would definitely um back that up and say
certainly if it's getting in the way of
your time with God so one little tip
that I I do and and I'll tell people
this in seminars is I have my phone
across the room for
nighttime um so it's several feet away
and it acts as like a little clock I can
see in the night and and things like
that and it's in little dock that my son
3D printed for me which is really cool
anyway um so the alarm goes off in the
morning and I have to get up and I have
to go over and I hit stop mhm not snooze
not snooze but stop and then you have to
develop that habit of walking away mhm
because so many people get caught up in
the as soon as I grab it now I see all
the things that I missed overnight oh
here's this email here's this social
media post or whatever and then the next
thing you know an hour went by right so
you have to develop that habit of and I
think the things help like the physical
distance right you have to get up and do
something about it hit stop now you have
to walk away You're creating more
physical distance or you could just use
an alarm clock that's another way you
can handle it right just keep your phone
tucked away wake up before your device
does right and go to bed after your
device does that kind of stuff anyway uh
last text I wanted to bring up was
Romans 1311 it says and do and do this
knowing the time that now it is high
time to awake out of sleep for now our
Salvation is nearer than we first
believed so what Paul is referring to
here is the end of time right it's every
day that goes by we're closer and closer
to the end of time knowing that knowing
that we're approaching the End of Time
the text
says wake
up right it's time to wake up in other
words don't be just living life
without aim don't be living life in and
stuck in some addictive habit like
engage with the world around you there
are people to be reached for Christ and
you know it says our Salvation is nearer
than we first believe and another words
Jesus is coming back he is even at the
door so God has a plan for you he has a
plan for your life and he wants to
empower you to engage with the world
around you so these are few principles
we can go by biblically
in order to um you know be free and be
engaged with Jesus not our phones not
our apps I like what you said there that
you use this verse looking at the time
that we're at you know if you read
Matthew 24 it Des signs of at times we
are so close um and if you read
Revelation 2 and 3 it talks about the
seven churches of Revelation which many
scholars from different denominations
believe these are were literal churches
in the time of Paul their most situation
in Turkey but that this were also
symbolic of the church in the future
from his time and we are currently in
the last Church the seventh church
called Le deia which is known to be
lukewarm you're not hot you're not cold
Jesus said if you stay lukewarm I will
spew you out of my mouth not because he
wants to but because it's a it's a bad
taste in his mouth that we're so sinful
and holding on to our idols and our sins
that he's like it's it's an involuntary
action um and also understanding that
according to Daniel and revelation we
are currently going through the Judgment
there's a judgment happening in heaven
where we're we're being judged and for
those of you who don't know this I
actually we have a different podcast
called the little life Studios podcast
Spotify Apple podcast wherever you
listen to them and I talked to Keith all
about this so we go in depth into why we
believe there is a judgment happening
right now but having that in my mind I'm
like we have to live differently you
know it's not like we can just sit there
and like you know just like scroll on
Tik Tok scroll on YouTube and oh Jesus
coming um I'm going to heaven and it's
you go to heaven and like what oh
there's no tiktk here oh I actually have
to like like spend more time with God
that I'm not used to you want enjoy
Heaven you know we have to be ready now
today the day of your salvation amen
yeah the Bible says that we are bought
with a price and one thing I you
know one thing I challenge people with
is knowing that if if you're bought by
God and the Bible says you're not your
own right mm therefore um you know what
do what do you do in light of that if if
you're not your own you belong to God
doesn't it seem reasonable to go to him
and be like hey God how should I be
living my life instead of you saying I'm
in the driver's seat I'm going to
determine how this thing plays out yep
you know you have a responsibility given
the price that God paid for you to come
to him and say I'm all yours what do you
what can I do and he knows know what's
best like he wants what's best for us if
he's asking you to let go of something
he's it's because he wants to replace it
with something better so I hope that was
helpful to all of you and uh make sure
you leave some comments make sure you
subscribe make sure you uh give us a
thumbs up and share this video we want
this to get out there far and wide make
sure that if you're passionate about
supporting Ministries like this that you
um you know give as God leads we have a
URL you can do that it's llsv /give
there other ways you can help us we have
merch on lightwear do shop that you can
get Faith moves mountains and he's
wearing an exclusive uh donor shirt so
if you become a donor by donating uh you
might end up with one of these so anyway
thank you for joining us and
participating in the conversation and uh
give us some feedback we'd like to know
what you think and we will see you next
time
[Music]
oh